สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครูฟ้าวันนี้วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้วันพุธ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 24
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือน
พฤษภาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันอังคาร
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 23
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือน
พฤษภาคม
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศอะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
พรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะ
พรุ่งนี้วัน
พฤหัสบดี
ค่ะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 25
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนพฤษภาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูฟ้าตอนนี้เวลา
5 ทุ่ม
[เพลง]
:00 นค่ะ
23:26 น
กลางคืนนะคะตอนนี้ครูฟ้าอยู่ออสเตรเลีย
ครูฟ้าบอกว่าที่ออสเตรเลียเนี่ยหนาวมาก
ใช่ไหม
ใช่ค่ะโอ้โหวันนี้มัน
เช็คให้นะคะนักเรียน
ตอนนี้เนี่ย 3 องศาแล้วนะคะ
3 องศา
แต่ว่ามันหนาวมากอ่ะมันหนาวมากๆมันมีลม
ไหมมีลมไหมคะ
[เพลง]
ครูฟ้าก็เลยหนาวมากเพราะว่าจริงๆสามองศา
เนี่ยมันหนาวแต่พอมันมีลมมันก็ทำให้หนาว
มากขึ้นไงคะอืมใช่ค่ะมีลมก็หนาวมาก
อุณหภูมิ 3 มีลมแล้วฝนตกไหมคะ
วันนี้ฝนไม่ตกค่ะบางวันฝนตกแต่วันนี้ไม่
ตกเวลาฝนตกเนี่ยหนาวมากขึ้นอีกไหม
ใช่ค่ะเวลาฝนตกหนาวมาก
ครูฟ้าไม่ได้เหนื่อย
เหนื่อยแบบพูดภาษาไทยเหนื่อยทำงานร้าน
อาหารนะเหนื่อยกับหนาวใช่ไหม
ใช่เพราะว่าอากาศหนาวอ่ะมันหายใจไม่โอเค
ไง
เหนื่อยเหนื่อยแต่ว่าหายใจ
หายใจไม่โอเคในอากาศหนาว
อ๋อใช่เพราะว่าเวลาที่เราเหนื่อยปกติเรา
จะแบบ
หายใจเร็วๆอยู่แล้วเพราะอากาศมันหนาวมัน
เย็นมันก็เย็นจมูกแล้วเวลาเราหายใจเข้าไป
มันจะรู้สึกเจ็บใช่ไหม
แต่ที่ออสเตรเลียเนี่ยฝนตกฝนตกเบาๆใช่ไหม
คะเขาเรียกอะไรนะ
ฝนตกเบาๆ
ปล่อย
ๆใช่ค่ะออสเตรเลียฝนตกนิดหน่อย
แต่ถ้าเป็นที่ไทยนะคะที่ไทยเนี่ยเขาก็บอก
ว่าตั้งแต่วันที่
พฤษภาคม
2023 เนี่ยนะคะ
ตั้งแต่วันนี้เนี่ย 20  2  23  24 เนี่ย
ประเทศไทยเนี่ยฝนจะตกฝนจะเริ่มตกแล้วอาจ
จะตกทุกวันทุกวันทุกวันเพราะว่าเดือน
พฤษภาคมเนี่ยประเทศไทยจะเป็นฤดูฝน
ตกฝนตกแรงมากๆไม่ได้ตกปรอยๆออสเตรเลีย
เนี่ยปรอยๆแบบนี้ใช่ไหมคะแต่ที่ไทยเนี่ย
นักเรียนฝนตกมากๆเลยแรงมากๆ
ถ้าฝนตกแล้วเราอยู่บ้านโอเค
ผู้หญิงชอบไหมคะเวลาฝนตกแล้วคุณหญิงอยู่
ที่บ้าน
ตอบค่ะเพราะที่ประเทศไทยถ้าฝนตกเนี่ยมัน
จะร้อนน้อยลง
ทำให้เราเย็นใช่ไหม
ใช่อย่าฝนยังไม่ตกเนี่ยอาจจะซัก 38 องศา
ร้อนมากๆใช่ไหมคะพอฝนตกมันจะลดลงอาจจะ
เหลือแบบ 33
องศาอย่างนี้แล้วก็มีฝนมีลมอยู่บ้านก็
ไปที่เตียงเลยค่ะ
แล้วก็นอนสบายแต่ถ้าฝนตกแล้วเราไม่ได้
อยู่บ้าน
อยู่ออฟฟิศกำลังทำงานทำงาน
แล้วก็ห้ามโมง
5 โมง
เลิกงาน
แล้วก็เดินออกมาแล้วก็เห็น
ฝนตก
ไม่ชอบเหรอคะผู้หญิงเราเลิกงานจับทำงาน
เสร็จกลับบ้านฝนตกเย็น
ถ้าคุณเลิกงาน 5 โมงแล้วเดินออกมาเจอฝนตก
ก็ถึงบ้านก็
20:00 นค่ะถึงบ้าน
2 ทุ่ม
ใช่ไหม
ถนนก็มีรถ
รถๆๆๆมากๆหรือว่ารถไม่มีปกติเลิกงาน 5
โมงซัก 6 โมงครึ่งถึงบ้านถ้าฝนตกก็อาจจะ 2
ทุ่ม
3 ทุ่ม
แล้วถ้าเราไม่มีร่มใช่ไหมคะอย่างครูฟ้า
อยู่เมื่อก่อนครูฟ้าอยู่ประเทศไทยมาทำงาน
ที่กรุงเทพฯ
เวลาช่วงช่วงฤดูฝนเนาะเดือนพฤษภาคมถึง
ประมาณตุลาคม
ฝนจะตกบ่อยๆเวลาครูฟ้าไปออฟฟิศครูฟ้า
เนี่ย
เอาร่มไปด้วยไหม
เวลาครูฟ้าไปออฟฟิศ
แล้วถ้าตอนที่คุณฟ้าเรียนหนังสือล่ะเรียน
หนังสือแล้วครูฟ้าไปเรียน
สายจัดบ้านแล้วก็ไปโรงเรียนเรียนหนังสือ
ครูฟ้าเอาร่มไปไหม
ไม่
ใช่เราเนี่ยบางครั้งแบบร่มเรามีกระเป๋า
สำหรับผู้หญิงก็จะมีกระเป๋าอย่างนี้
กระเป๋าก็จะใหญ่นะคะนักเรียนร่มเนี่ยเวลา
มันพับมันจะเป็นยังไงอย่างนี้ป่ะ
ใช่
จริงๆร่มเนี่ยเอาใส่ในกระเป๋าได้แต่มัน
หนักอ่ะ
ค่ะผู้หญิง
เห็นคุยกัน
ใช่ไหม
ไม่เป็นไรหรอกเราทำงานอย่างเมื่อก่อนคุย
หญิงกับครูฟ้าทำงานเนี่ยเราจะทำงานเสร็จ
ประมาณ
เราสองคนเนี่ยทำงานเสร็จสมัยก็ถ้าฝนตกก็
คิดโอเคฝนตกเราก็เดิน MRT  Subway แต่ถ้า
ฝนไม่ตกผู้หญิงก็อาจจะไป BTS
ก็ไม่ต้องใช้ร่มไง
ผู้หญิงกลับบ้านได้ 2 ทางเลยหรอคะใช่ๆค่ะ
มี MRT ก็คือ Subway ไม่ต้องออกไปข้างนอก
เดินจากออฟฟิศแล้วก็ลงๆๆแล้วก็เดินๆๆ MRT
ได้เลยแต่ถ้าวันไหนฝนตกใช่ไหมถ้าฝนตกเข้า
ไป MRT แต่ถ้าฝนไม่ตกก็เดินมาทางนี้ BTS
[เพลง]
บางครั้งอาจจะเรียกแท็กซี่ซึ่งมันอาจจะ
ต้องเดินออกมาข้างนอกแล้วก็เจอฝน
จะไปเจอฝนเนี่ย
มีฝนฝน
ตกอยู่แล้วไม่มีร่ม
ปกติครูฟ้าทำยังไงอ่ะถ้าครูฟ้าเดินออกมา
เจอฝนแล้วแบบกลับเข้าไปในออฟฟิศไม่ได้
แล้วหรือว่ากลับบ้านไม่ได้แล้วจะต้องไป
เจอเพื่อนไปกินข้าวกับเพื่อนหรือว่าเลิก
งานแล้วกลับบ้านก็ได้อ่ะค่ะแล้วไม่มีร่ม
อ่ะ
เคยคิดนะคะนักเรียนว่า
เพราะว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ย
ครูฟ้าทำงานเสร็จใช่ไหมเราก็เดินเออออกมา
แล้วฝนก็ตกหนักมากในประเทศไทยฝนตกหนักมาก
ๆครูฟ้าก็เลยทำยังไงดีไม่มีร่มแล้วก็เห็น
ว่าต้องหาหนึ่งเลยนะคะ 1 ครูบอกต้องหาที่
หลบฝน
คืออะไรก็ได้นะคะนักเรียนที่มีข้างบน
เนี่ยหลังที่เราจะหลบ
ฝนก่อน
อาจจะยืนอยู่ตรงนี้ใช่ไหมมีหลังคายืนฝน
เนี่ยอาจจะไม่ได้ลงมาแบบนี้แกะยังไงแต่ก็
อาจจะมีลมนิดหน่อย
ครูฟ้าก็จะหาที่หลบฝนก่อนแล้วก็ดูใช่ไหม
คะว่าฝนตกหนักแค่ไหนใช่คือฟ้าเนี่ยเคยมี
อยู่ 1 ครั้งเพราะว่าทำงานเสร็จนะ
คะมาถึงออกมาประมาณ 1 ทุ่มแล้วมั้ง
แล้วฟ้าก็ไปหาที่หลบที่หลบฝนมันก็มี
ช็อปปิ้งมอลล์ใกล้ๆนะคะเป็นห้างมันก็เลย
เดินเข้าไปในห้างแล้วก็นั่งรอ
แต่ฝนไม่หยุดน่ะ
มานั่งรอ 1 ชั่วโมงแล้วค่ะ
1 ชั่วโมงใช่นักเรียนไทยมันฝนตกอ่ะ
คือมันตกได้แบบเป็น 2 ชั่วโมงเลยนะ
มันนานมากนะคะก็เลยคิดว่าถ้าครูฟ้านั่งรอ
แบบนี้มาก็จะ
ไม่ได้กลับบ้านแล้วครูฟ้าก็ไม่รู้ว่าฝนจะ
ตกงานแค่ไหนไงอาจจะตก 3 ชั่วโมง 4
ชั่วโมงแล้วจะทำยังไงกูก็ต้องไปทำงาน
พรุ่งนี้ก็ต้องไปทำงานใช่ไหมแล้วครูฟักก็
อยากนอนไงว่าก็เลยคิดว่าจะเดินออกมาหา
แท็กซี่นะคะ
ก็เลยเดินๆออกมาแล้วกันไปเห็น
ไม่มีแท็กซี่เลยอ่ะ
แบบคนก็เยอะแท็กซี่ไม่มี
น้องเขาคิดทำยังไงดี
จะกลับไปรอในในห้าง
ก็ไม่อยากไปวาก็เลย
เดินตาม
ก็คือ
ไม่มีร่มแล้วก็ไม่หาอะไรเลยใช่ไหมฝนก็ตก
อันนี้ก็เป็นถนนใช่ไหมมีฟุตบาท
1 ชั่วโมงมั้ง
ฟ้าเปียกเลยแบบเปียก 100% นะคะนักเรียนฝน
ตกฝนตกฝนตก
ก็ยืนกอดกระเป๋า
ทำไมครูฟ้าอยู่ใน shopping  center ครู
ฟ้าไม่หาซื้ออันนี้
เขาเรียกอะไรอ่ะเสื้อกันฝนอ่ะ
คือตอนนั้นไม่ได้คิดไงคิดไม่ออกแล้วนะคะ
เพราะว่าคิดไม่ออกว่าลูกไม่อยากกลับบ้าน
Center ข้างในมันเป็น
KFC  Mcdonald ข้างล่างใช่ไหมมันก็จะมี
แบบแฟชั่นขายเสื้ออะไรอย่างนี้แค่นั้นน่ะ
[เพลง]
หรือว่า
คนไทยบางคนเนี่ยถ้าถ้าสมมุติว่าถ้าอยู่ใน
สมุดอยู่ใน shopping  center หรืออะไร
หรืออยู่ในเซเว่นอีเลฟเว่นอย่างนี้ค่ะถ้า
ไม่มีไม่มีเสื้อกันฝน
ไม่มีเสื้อกันฝนแล้วหรือว่าเราอยู่ที่
ออฟฟิศสมัยครูฟ้าอยู่ออฟฟิศกำลังจะกลับ
บ้านแล้วก็เห็นว่าฝนตกร่มไม่มีอีกหนึ่ง
อย่างที่ช่วยได้นะครูฟ้าโอเคเรายังเปียก
นะคะแต่หัวเราจะโอเค
อะไรคะ
ถุงพลาสติก
ออฟฟิศที่ประเทศไทยทุกออฟฟิศแหละจะมีถุง
พลาสติก
เหรอคะคุณหญิงเข้ามาทำอะไร
นักเรียนไปซื้อของที่พวกเทสโก้โลตัส
บิ๊กซีซุปเปอร์มาร์เก็ตอ่ะค่ะแล้วเขาก็จะ
เอาแอปเปิ้ลเอาส้มเอาของแล้วก็ใส่ถุง
พลาสติกอ่ะ
หรือว่าคนไทยเรียกถุงก๊อบแก๊บเนี่ยนะคะ
ถุงพลาสติกอันเนี้ยใช้ได้เราก็ถุงพลาสติก
เนี่ยมาใส่ที่หัว
ของครูฟ้า
ได้ไงครูฟ้าก็อันนี้ใช่ไหมอันนี้ครูฟ้า
แล้วคุณฟ้าก็ถุงพลาสติกเนี่ยมาใส่
ที่นี่เวลาครูฟ้าเดิน
อันนี้ไม่ใช่ปากนะคะนักเรียน
ฝนตกเนี่ยตัวตัวของเราเนี่ยก็เปียกแต่หัว
โอเคคนไทยเนี่ยนะคะจะชอบคิดว่าถ้าเวลาฝน
ตกเราต้องดูแลหัวหัวเนี่ยห้ามเปียกฝน
เดี๋ยวไม่สบายแต่จริงๆแล้ว scientist
มาใส่ที่หัวเวลาฝนตกแล้วไม่มีร่ม
แล้วมันมีมากกว่านั้นอีกนะบางคนก็ไม่มี
ถุงพลาสติกใช่ไหมอาจจะหาไม่ได้อ่ะค่ะ
เมื่อก่อนแล้วกันเนาะเพราะว่าเมื่อก่อน
เนี่ยเราอ่านหนังสือพิมพ์สวยบางกอกโพสต์
นิวยอร์กไทม์พวกหนังสือพิมพ์อย่างนี้ค่ะ
บางผู้ชายอ่ะผู้ชายบางคนเขาก็จะมีหนังสือ
พิมพ์หรือในออฟฟิศก็มีหนังสือพิมพ์บาง
ครั้งเราก็จะเอาถุงพลาสติกเนี่ยเราเห็น
ใช่ไหมว่าอุ๊ยฝนตกโอเคเอาถุงพลาสติกใส่
หัวแล้วก็เอาหนังสือพิมพ์หนังสือพิมพ์มัน
จะค่อนข้างใหญ่เวลามันพับมันจะค่อนข้าง
ใหญ่ใช่ไหมอ่าแล้วเราก็ต้องทิ้งอยู่ดีอ่ะ
หนังสือพิมพ์เนี่ยเราทิ้งเราอ่านอ่าน
เสร็จแล้วเราก็ทิ้งใช่ไหมคะแล้วก็ส่ง
พลาสติกใส่หัวแล้วก็มือนี้ก็ถือหนังสือ
พิมพ์
อีกหนึ่งครั้ง
คือเราก็เปียกนะคะมันก็ยังเปียกอยู่นัก
เรียนหนังสือพิมพ์มันก็คือกระดาษอ่ะ
กระดาษพอโดนฝนที่เป็นน้ำมันก็เปียกแต่ว่า
เราก็ปิดแล้วเราก็วิ่งไงวิ่งเหมือนครูฟ้า
บอกวิ่งแล้วก็หาแท็กซี่หามอเตอร์ไซค์
แท็กซี่ไงมันก็ช่วยหน่อยเราก็ตัวเปียกแต่
หัวโอเค
ก็โอเคนะ
ใช่
ถ้าเราหาร่มไงหาร่ม
ไม่ได้หรือว่าแบบพวกเสื้อกันฝนสมัยนี้
เสื้อกันฝนแบบนี้
เจอกันฝนเนี่ยไม่มีอ่ะเออหาไม่ได้ก็ถุง
พลาสติกหรือว่าหนังสือพิมพ์อันนี้ New
ใส่ได้นะคะหรือว่าถุงอะไรก็ได้ถ้าเรามี
ถุงช้อปปิ้งถุงซื้อของอยู่เอาของเนี่ยใส่
กระเป๋าแล้วก็เอาถุงเนี่ยมาใส่หัวของเรา
เอาไว้
หัวเราเนี่ยไม่โดนฝน
แต่จริงๆประเทศไทยมีเซเว่นอีเลฟเว่นเยอะ
มากนะคะนักเรียนนักเรียนลองหาเซเว่น
อีเลฟเว่นดูก่อนอาจจะเจอเซเว่นอีเลฟเว่น
เนี่ยจะมีเสื้อกันฝนขายนะคะประมาณ 29 บาท
มั้ง
29 บาทนะคะแต่เสื้อกันฝนเซเว่นอีเลฟเว่น
เนี่ยมันไซส์คนไทยไงผู้หญิงคิดว่าไซส์ L
เนี่ยก็น่าจะแบบผู้ชายไทยสูงซัก
170 เซนติเมตรเนี่ยโอเค
แต่ถ้านักเรียนนักเรียนสูง
180 เซนติเมตรขึ้นไปก็เสื้อก็อาจจะกัน
ได้แบบ 50% นะข้างล่างเนี่ยเปียก
แล้วก็เซเว่นอีเลฟเว่นก็มีร่มขายเนาะ
โอเคมากกว่าเนาะเดี๋ยวแล้วค่ะแล้วถ้าเป็น
นักเรียนล่ะคะถ้านักเรียนกำลังเดินอยู่
แล้วฝนตกแต่ไม่มีร่มนักเรียนจะทำยังไงก็
คอมเมนต์คุยกับเราได้นะส่วนวีดีโอนี้ครู
หญิงกับครูฟ้าไปก่อนนะคะแล้วเดี๋ยวเรามา
เจอกันใหม่สวัสดีค่ะ
[เพลง]